wie oft hast du schon antibiotika
genommen und wie oft hast du zu dir
genommen ohne davon mitzubekommen
ungefährlich ist das nicht in europa
sterben jährlich etwa 33.000 menschen an
antibiotika resistenten keimen und es
werden immer mehr
also ich glaube schon dass das
gesamtgesellschaftlichen richtiges
problem werden wird wenn die erreger
soweit mutiert und das irgendwie die
politiker gar nicht mehr helfen dann das
mag man sich nicht ausmalen also dann
gnade uns gott doch antibiotika nehmen
wir nicht nur als medizin zu uns sie
begegnen uns auch hier rund die hälfte
aller in deutschland verkauften
antibiotika landen in der tierhaltung
grundsätzlich ist antibiotika wichtig
dass wir zur verfügung haben wollte dass
für uns die tiere auch wieder gesunden
lässt unterdessen verlieren wir aber
wirksamer wirkstoffe aufgrund von der
zunahme von resistenten keimen corona
zeigt uns die dramatischen folgen einer
globalen pandemie droht uns die nächste
globale krankheitswelle wegen
resistenter keime sterben deswegen
menschen
mein name ist mathias hansmann und ich
hatte letztes jahr multiresistenten keim
und dadurch entstandene selbst ist und
eine lungenembolie matthias hansmann
leidet an einer nierenerkrankung erst
dialysepflichtig im monat endet machen
wir verschiedene check programme bei
unseren dauert da aber dann irgendwann
ein mrsa keim entdeckt mrsa keime waren
ursprünglich nur gegen das antibiotikum
methicillin resistent inzwischen haben
sie weitere resistenzen gegen mehrere
antibiotika ausgebildet
sie besiedeln insbesondere die haut und
die schleimhäute und können zu einer
blutvergiftung führen wenn sie in die
blutbahn gelangen
resistenzen sind gefährlich denn wir
sind auf die wirkung von antibiotika
angewiesen
doch warum entwickeln wir resistenzen
jeder einsatz von antibiotika fördert
ihre bildung empfindliche bakterien
werden abgetötet widerstandsfähige
jedoch überleben werden resistent und
vermehren sich weiter antibiotika
resistente erreger treten daher oft dort
auf wo viele antibiotika eingesetzt
werden das kann in kliniken seien aber
auch in der landwirtschaft
[Musik]
ich habe gedacht der ganze kram wieder
von vorne los ich habe den herrn doktor
meyer gefragt woran kann das liegen also
dass ich das immer wieder kriege im
gegensatz zu früher frage hier
inzwischen immer patienten nach den
lebensumständen genauer wiewohl sie was
ist in ihrer nähe
im umkreis von 1000 metern so meine
wohnung lag praktisch dorfmitte über
eine bäckerei und nach hinten raus war
ein kuhstall wenn ich das fenster
geöffnet habe der erste geruch warm ist
also kuhmist und
im sommer auch viel staub wenn es
richtig trocken war
dann hat sie ihm erzählt habe wo ich
wohne da hat er dann schon die ersten
vermutungen angestellt dass er das ist
daran liegen könnte
üblicherweise kommen mrsa keime zu fünf
prozent aus der tierhaltung und zu 95
prozent aus der humanmedizin in regionen
mit intensiver tierhaltung jedoch sieht
das ganz anders aus
beinahe 30 prozent der keime stammen
hier aus der tierhaltung und nur 71
prozent aus der humanmedizin die keime
sind in der stahl luft enthalten und
dringen so nach draußen
matthias hansmann glaubt dass er
resistente keime über die stahl luft
eingeatmet habe bewiesen ist das nicht
doch die resistenten bakterien finden
sich nicht nur in der luft sondern auch
in unserem essen 59 proben aus großen
billig discountern zeigen dramatisches
die wissenschaftler fanden resistente
keime bei lidl in 33 prozent der
fleischproben bei real ebenso 33 prozent
bei netto in 58 prozent bei aldi in 75
prozent und bei penny in 82 prozent der
untersuchten fleischproben diese keime
auf dem fleisch stellen ein großes
risiko für uns da bei der zubereitung
sehen wir sie nicht so können sie zb
über unsere hände oder spritzwasser vom
fleisch auf andere lebensmittel gelangen
und gerade die umstände in der
massentierhaltung sind für eine
verbreitung ideal ist natürlich diese
tiere immer geschwächt sind
zwischen den tieren natürlich dann auch
unheimlich schnell weiter verbreiten
kann
wir wollen von einem landwirt wissen ob
sich die vergabe von antibiotika
vermeiden lässt mit sicherheit behandeln
wird tiere die in dem moment nicht eine
akute erkrankung zeigen die aber mit
sicherheit ja dem gesamt druck im stall
ausgesetzt sind wir müssen einfach vorne
vorweg gehen um einfach die erkrankung
und braucht zu verhindern ein gutes jahr
ist wenn ich wirklich maximal ein
viertel der tiere zu beginn der maßnahme
muss und schlechtes wenn ich mehr als
die hälfte
der stelle einmal zu anfang der mast
behandeln müsste das wäre für mich
schlecht die weltgesundheitsorganisation
whu hat eine liste unentbehrlicher
arzneimittel herausgebracht antibiotika
sind hier in drei gruppen eingeteilt
entscheidend ist die dritte die
sogenannte reserve gruppe als letzte
reserve sollten diese antibiotika nur
eingesetzt werden wenn alle anderen
mittel versagt haben
der sparsame einsatz nur im notfall soll
verhindern dass bakterien gegen diese
letzte reserve resistent werden
doch die verwendung von
reserveantibiotika insbesondere in der
intensivtierhaltung nimmt zu das liegt
daran dass die meisten reserve
antibiotika sehr viel potenter sind mit
der gleichen menge kann man viel mehr
tiere behandeln von allen antibiotika
die in der geflügelmast eingesetzt
werden sind 40 prozent reserve
antibiotika und das zeigt uns das system
kann nicht ohne sie können nicht weiter
reduzieren die masse an antibiotika die
dort verbraucht werden und dann brauchen
sie offensichtlich die letzten mittel
die überhaupt noch leben
doch trotz der weltweiten zunahme von
resistenten erregern sind in den letzten
jahrzehnten kaum neue antibiotika auf
den markt gekommen um so sparsamer
sollte also mit den reserven umgegangen
werden
wenn keine effektiven gegenmaßnahmen
getroffen werden könnten resistente
bakterien bis zum jahr 2050 jährlich
mehr menschen umbringen als krebs eine
entwicklung die für uns alle bedrohlich
werden kann
findet ihr es sollte strengere
regulierung für den einsatz von
antibiotika in der landwirtschaft geben
schreibt es uns in die kommentare
[Musik]